déjà comment elle va Rochelle mais je
l'avais
rencontrés de dos des examens à passer
elle va pas bien chez psychologiquement
là
pas trop le moral en plus là avec si je
sors elle a été un peu déçu aussi on
parlait ce qui s'est passé c'est que
après le l'agression elle est elle
essaie de minimiser les choses et après
je pense que c'est rendu compte aussi de
de la gravité elle a après ça j'ai
l'impression que plus le temps passe
plus elle en souffre parce que au début
pour elle elle a pas été agressée elle a
cru qu'elle était tombée donc sur le
moment elle a rien vu elle a rien vu de
l'agression c'est après quand quand
s'est retrouvé à l'hôpital avec les
pompiers et tout qui l'ont soigné que
puis là maintenant il y a les douleurs
qui sortent un peu de partout elle a des
examens à passer et voilà alors le
procès lieu c'était hier ça oui
bien sûr toute la France tous ceux qui
nous regardent tous ceux qui ont suivi
l'affaire et vous êtes voilà toute la
France a suivi cette affaire qui nous a
tout choqué on attendait tous ce verdict
alors maître jaouette Dany avocat
d'Angèle qu'est-ce qui s'est passé à
l'audience de mercredi quel est le
verdict l'audience de mercredi c'était
une audience de culpabilité parce que
pour les mineurs il y a 2 temps le temps
de l'audience de culpabilité où on va où
la juridiction va se prononcer sur le
fait de savoir si ces trois prévenus
vont être déclarés coupables ou pas et
vous l'avez dit Cyril deux d'entre eux
ont été déclarés coupables a été relaxé
et celui qui a filmé relaté relaxer
pourquoi en fait juridiquement le
parquet avait décidé de poursuivre pour
les deux qui ont été condamnés violence
en réunion vol avec violence en réunion
et celui qui filmait on avait décidé en
tout cas le parquet avait décidé de le
poursuivre pour complicité de violence
en réunion or dans le dossier la
juridiction a estimé qu'il n'y avait pas
d'éléments objectifs pour pouvoir le
maintenir dans les liens de la
prévention pour complicité de violence
par contre et ça je ne travaille aucun
dans le 10 ans il avait reconnu l'effet
il avait dit que il avait reconnu le
fait d'avoir filmé la scène c'est parce
qu'en fait si on avait visé si le
procureur ou le parquet avait visé le
texte de happy slapping par exemple
c'est une infraction autonome il aurait
été condamné ou non à 660 personnes en
danger ou le fait de retenir une scène
unique de violence en réunion ou les
trois quel que soit leur participation
aurait pu être confondues dans les liens
donc comme on l'a dit les deux sont
placés pendant 6 mois et relaxer mais la
vraie décision qui fait énormément
parler c'est celle-ci Gilles puisque
apparemment la famille voilà ne peuvent
plus exercer c'est quoi l'histoire alors
ça c'est donc la famille d'un des
agresseurs c'est ça alors on avait reçu
Bouchaib exactement voilà donc moi j'ai
eu Asma qui est la sœur aînée de l'un
des agresseurs
quel est le verdict là tu ils sont quoi
alors ils ne peuvent plus travailler au
marché ils sont forts ils ont un bazar
d'accord marché de La Bocca tous les
samedis c'est leur seul rien de
subsistance et donc la mairie de Cannes
ils ont été reçus hier le maire adjoint
elle aura encore dit vous ne pouvez plus
travailler votre emplacement ne vous
sera plus octroyé jusqu'à l'énoncé de la
peine le 28 juin donc cette famille
et jugé coupable par la mairie je prends
pas parti un génance les faits parce que
son fils a agressé en gel donc eux ils
n'ont plus rien et ça c'est un vrai
événement parce que c'est très rare
alors René est-ce que vous êtes
satisfait de ces décisions ou est-ce que
pour vous c'est c'est juste parce que
bon de toute manière ces enfants ils
sont mal éduquer
donc on peut pas ça c'est normal de
sanctionner les les
reçus ici quand ce truc j'avais dit je
suis désolé pour vous je suis désolé que
ça vous crée des problèmes pour le
travail mais ma mère elle a pas demandé
à être agressée non plus
on a plus le droit de de condamner un
mineur donc alors il faut faire quoi
alors mettre oui j'aimerais commence à
porter une précision c'est que en fait
est-ce qu'on parle du verdict du
jugement pour les jeunes ou en ce qu'on
parle de la décision de la mairie il y a
les deux alors le verdict pour les
jeunes donc c'est 6 mois pour les gens
on est pas satisfait en partie alors
pour les jeunes vous n'êtes pas
satisfaits on n'est pas satisfait pour
les jeunes parce que il y a eu la relax
par contre et ça c'est important du 3e
qui finit du 3e qui filme on l'a dit
mais pour ma femme hein et on s'en
félicite puisque
ils vont faire appel et soit donc il va
être jugé pour les MP soit ils vont le
recycler avec la qualification par
contre et ce qui est important de dire
c'est que c'est d'ailleurs un peu mon
rôle moi je suis l'avocat de de d'Angel
c'est la place de la de la victime dans
le procès est-ce qu'on a véritablement
trouvé sa place dans ce procès est-ce
que elle a pu trouver des des excuses
satisfaisantes est-ce que son préjudice
aujourd'hui est résorbé moi je suis
surtout là pour parler d'Angel parce que
pour moi
la place d'Angel il faut qu'elle
retrouve sa place de victime après
effectivement la famille et je rejoins
monsieur Verdez la famille elle a une
difficulté avec la mairie qui leur a
enlevé le banc ça pour le coup en tant
que partie civile on n'a pas prononcé
d'ailleurs Angel elle a elle a rien à
voir dans le fait qu'on était enlevé
alors vous autour de la date vous avez
vos petites Pancar est-ce que vous êtes
dans du jugement déjà pour les deux
est-ce que vous trouvez que c'est c'est
voilà six mois et un relaxer est-ce que
vous trouvez que ça sera voilà en juin
qu'on aura vraiment il risque jusqu'à 5
ans 5 ans et 7500 € exactement le 28
juin on aura vraiment la décision et ce
qui fait encore plus parler c'est vrai
que c'est cette histoire d'emplacement à
l'Amérique alors vous avez vu la famille
oui j'ai eu un SMA donc et elle elle me
dit que était venue elle était venu à ce
moment c'était une autre sœur c'était
une autre sœur qui était venue c'est la
sœur exactement donc elle ce qu'elle dit
c'est que d'abord ils acceptent la
famille accepte la peine qui serait
infligée en juin et ne défend pas ça ils
l'ont toujours le frère absolument
là-dessus ils sont parfaits mais en
revanche qui ne comprennent pas c'est
que non plus de ressources ils sont
privés de tout par une décision de
l'Amérique qu'il juge eux arbitraire ils
ne peuvent plus exercer le samedi le
remplacement là qui était depuis des
années réservé fini donc ils n'ont plus
de ressources la maman selon Asma n'a
pas d'allocations donc c'est très
compliqué ils ne peuvent plus vivre ils
empruntent de l'argent et ils payent
pour leur enfant et ça ça crée un débat
voilà un vrai débat vous vous en pensez
quoi moi je pense que les parents comme
la justice française de stipule n'ont
pas à payer pour un enfant c'est
l'enfant c'est le coupable français qui
doit répondre alors ça c'est le vrai
débat ça parce que c'est pas d'accord
je pense pas que les parents doivent
payer le prix de ce que font les enfants
je pense que l'éducation aujourd'hui
c'est très dur pour beaucoup de parents
beaucoup de parents n'arrivent pas à
gérer leur enfant alors certains diront
oui mais un enfant n'a rien à faire
dehors après 8 heures le soir etc mais
il y a des parents qui tiennent pas il y
a des parents qui n'y arrivent pas donc
les parents essayent donc moi je pense
que pour moi là c'est un débat compliqué
je pense pas qu'il faille enlever
peut-être le travail je sais pas si
c'est dû à ça aux parents etc bon et
bien pour moi c'est pas normal je pense
qu'il faut je pense qu'on inverse un peu
tout je pense que la peine qu'on donne
aux parents il faudrait l'accumuler à
celle des enfants et plutôt que par les
6 mois les enfants et 6 mois enfermés
dans leur sens c'est pas on va voir il y
a le voilà il faudrait pour moi les
mettre en prison et qui prennent parce
que là c'est c'est beaucoup trop facile
à mon sens j'ai une question pour
l'avocat pour mettre comment se fait-il
qu'il y ait qu'une seule famille qui
était dont les parents étaient punis
pourquoi dans l'autre famille
punit pas a prioriage
administrative qui n'a rien à voir avec
le procès pénal en réalité la mairie a
pris la décision seule moi je suis
avocat donc j'interviens d'un point de
vue juridique la mairie a décidé
d'enlever le banc à cette famille
pourquoi les autres ça je ne sais pas et
les autres se sont présentés à
l'audience et donc ces gens peuvent se
retourner contre la mairie pour décision
arbitraire et en fait ces gens-là
doivent régler la difficulté avec la
mairie la mairie a décidé de soutenir
donc je sais que le maire a été
extrêmement choqué comme la France il a
eu des mots très forts très dur il a été
humain incroyable dans ce qu'il a fait
le maire de Cannes une fois de plus
voilà il a osé dire des choses que aucun
responsable politique n'ose dire et
voilà je trouve qu'il a été
incroyablement là-dessus on est d'accord
c'est vrai que voilà c'est mais la
décision prise par la mairie si vous me
permettez Cyril la décision prise par la
mairie elle a été prise unilatéralement
par la mairie rien à voir avec la
justice exactement alors Delphine toi tu
trouves que c'est normal autant autant
quand le papa était venu là voilà on
comprenait que c'était un bon papa parce
que vu l'éducation de sa fille c'était
pas une question d'éducation c'est une
question d'entourage c'est pour ça que
les parents doivent faire attention à
l'entourage néanmoins pour les
délinquants mineurs je pense que s'il y
avait une loi qui permettait aussi
d'emmener les parents un peu dans la
chute c'est-à-dire que les parents
soient aussi punis je pense que les
jeunes réfléchiraient à deux fois parce
que aucun jeûne même s'il veut le mal à
autrui ne veut pas le mal à ses propres
parents et donc ça les ferait peut-être
réfléchir
de la peine à la peine et effectivement
je pense par exemple à des mamans qui
sont par exemple des mamans solo qui
travaillent qui partent à 8h du matin
qui rentre à 20h qui essaye de tenir
leur enfant et qu'il n'y arrive pas
alors moi je pense que d'abord il
faudrait des paliers des paliers d'aide
par exemple la mairie qui pourrait aider
tant de la main etc et éventuellement si
on voit que la mer ou les parents sont
défaillants après les avoir aidés à
plusieurs reprises là au bout du bout du
bout peut-être pourquoi pas mais pas
comme ça
il y a quelques mois sur cette sanction
des parents je trouvais que c'était
injuste parce qu'il y avait parfois des
petits frères etc mais j'ai l'impression
que si on ne fait pas ça ça va être très
compliqué d'essayer de ramener les
jeunes entre guillemets le droit chemin
c'est un peu on peut mais je trouve que
effectivement l'ambiance est-elle quand
je vois les images de cette dame qui est
fracassée par un membre de 14 ans je me
dis quand même que même si les parents
ne sont pas directement responsable au
bout d'un moment faire attention à
quelle heure il rentre essayer de les
encadrer etc je pense que vraiment il va
falloir que les parents soient
effectivement comme tu l'as dit un peu
emmené avec l'eau du bain parce que
sinon ça ne s'arrêtera jamais prenez moi
ce qui m'a gêné le plus dans ce truc
c'est que
j'ai pas trouvé de ils avaient une
lettre et qu'ils ont eu devant ma mère
c'était une lettre d'excuse une lettre
d'excuse qu'ils ont lieu devant un maire
pour moi
parce que les mots qu'ils emploient un
jeune de 14 ans c'est pas lui qui va
écrire ça il y avait pas une faute rien
du tout hein
il était incapable de la lire que
quelqu'un qui est fait une lettre il est
truc et j'ai pas vu de l'arme j'ai
jamais vu j'aurais préféré qu'il y ait
pas de lettre c'est ça ouais et qui
s'exprime avec le cœur exactement
c'est des grosses merdes son père il
défend son fils pour moi
il est fautif et puis c'est tout il a
pas frappé c'est parce que là ils ont
pas c'est pas un procès de voilà
l'étalage c'est quand même une agression
qui est importante il faut que ça arrête
il y en a trop il y en a trop et c'est
vrai que
moi je veux dire ces histoires de
lettres tout ça j'ai pas j'ai
franchement j'ai pas sentiments
qui disent vraiment ce qui ressent
plutôt de leur écrire
et en liberté peut-être ce soir il est
encore dans la rue à faire des des
conneries
il était quand même un peu agressif
celui-là aussi
vous n'êtes pas du tout content de la
décision
je trouvais que c'est quoi c'est
quoi
c'est une arnaque c'est une fumée
la question pour savoir pour savoir
lequel c'est qui avait donné le départ
de la guerre il se ça se baladait
c'était le plus bon vous avez été déçu
du procès
il aurait préféré qu'il y ait plus
d'émotions limite limite la peine ce que
je sens de René moi ça c'est limite la
peine il s'en fout il a le plus déçu
c'est que il a pas senti les jeunes
moi j'avais envie de partir en fait il y
avait pas d'enjeu de peine ce jour-là il
y avait un enjeu de culpabilité
seulement mais ce qu'attendait Angel
c'était déjà elle a fait l'effort de
venir
avec le coeur bon j'aurais pu plus de
trucs là bien sûr pour moi c'était la
première fois qu'elle affronté les trois
individus parce que l'agression et vous
l'avez vu sur les vidéos
plus lâche déjà par derrière il la
laisse sur le sol elle a décidé de venir
à l'audience chose qu'elle aurait pu
éviter elle vient à l'audience elle
reste plusieurs heures à l'audience elle
les affronte ils avaient quand même
trois trois mois pour se préparer je
veux dire c'est quand même une chance
inouïe bien sûr c'est ça
non non mais bien sûr mais bon on va
avoir des comptes parce que là moi je
quand on voit les images on se dit
je trouve ça étonnant qu'on juge en gros
ce qui s'est passé avec la légèreté
parce que là la violence du coup qui est
porté on voit que les gens elle est
extrêmement mauvais
si votre maman était décédée
le truc il parle de bousculer je vais
bousculer la dame et on va prendre le
sac mais là c'est pas bousculé
la Angèle votre maman était décédée
la personne qu'on dise que ces gamins
dégagent que on bosse pas que on serait
tous et concrètement quand le jeune
porte le coup on sent bien qu'il se dit
pas je fais pour que ça ne fasse pas
trop mal quoi on sent que c'est fait
pour 5 minutes après j'étais en train de
manger au truc avec les 30 euros quoi et
soi-disant ils ont ils étaient là qui
disait oh là là on a ça faisait du souci
et tout c'est en train de manger
tranquille avec 30 €. On est tu as pas
son site sincérité
je vais les familles ne soutiennent pas
les enfants évidemment la famille du
jeune mineur qui a tapé votre maman dit
notre propre mère avait essayé d'alerter
l'assistante sociale sur la dérive d'un
jeune ils n'ont pas été entendu moi je
les défends pas mais ce qui a vraiment
choqué moi j'ai regardé le bon procès à
huis clos mais les éléments que j'ai
Cyril ce qui a vraiment choqué c'est que
ces jeunes là légitimement défendus par
leur famille n'ont pas exprimé de
remords et ils sont arrivés vraiment
très dur au procès et ça pour la famille
d'Angèle c'est insupportable
il y a eu des il y a eu des regrets
exprimés
pour ce qui était obligé voilà c'est des
regrets un petit peu circonstances
circonstances et des regrets même la
lettre a été écrite par quelqu'un
d'autre c'est voilà c'est on a fait le
boulot quoi on a fait le taf c'est
exactement ça mais même le comportement
inapproprié tout au long de la procédure
après monsieur Verdez vous avez des
problèmes moi je suis un peu tenu mais
je suis un peu tenu par le secret
professionnel mais de manière générale
un comportement inapproprié de ces
jeunes avant les faits après l'effet
lorsqu'ils sont
déférés devant le procureur devant les
enquêteurs on sent une légèreté après la
justice
bah après ils sont partis en rigolant
après les filles là en fait on voit que
quelques secondes de la vidéo mais dans
le dossier on a une vidéo un peu plus
longue 5 minutes avant l'effet on les
voit suivre Angel donc c'est un peu
prémédité ensuite après l'effet on les
voit en rigueur après le procès est
rigoler il était comment après le procès
dans une rigolait pas par contre nous on
a senti quand même une certaine légèreté
dans leur comportement ça attendait à
beaucoup plus voilà juste pour pour
revenir sur un point important Angel
c'était elle a été brisée donc en fait
moi cette audience là un autre enjeu
c'était de demander une indemnisation
provisionnelle
tu es d'accord m'a donné à titre pas la
totalité mais une partie par contre
c'est pas la somme d'argent en réalité
qu'est-ce que ça coûte une vie brisée
Angel elle est brisée aujourd'hui n'ose
plus marcher dans la rue elle sort de
chez elle elle regarde toutes les deux
minutes dehors elle ne sort plus seul
elle a un préjudice moral important elle
a un préjudice physique important
aujourd'hui à 80 novembre comment on
peut réparer ce préjudice voilà ça c'est
une copie on pourra jamais le réparer
exactement
mais pour Angèle c'est un enfer elle a
rien demandé elle se retrouve pour des
excursions un procès elle subit à la 89
ans elle aimerait être tranquille je
pense et arrêter de voilà 89 ans elle
rentrait de ses courses elle avait deux
sacs dans les mains donc elle a rien
demandé
ma mère il jurait demandé les 30 euros
les aurais donné ma mère je suis sûr
bien sûr
on a envie d'aller on voudrait 33 ce que
vous avez quelque chose à nous donner je
suis sûr que les origines la preuve même
le premier coup qui l'ont interrogé à
l'hôpital la même dit c'est pas c'est
pas vrai
et la dignité dont elle a super preuve
tout au long de l'audience tout au long
en fait depuis l'effet vous voyez quand
elle est intervie interviewée elle a une
souffrance contenue elle va jamais
s'exprimer vraiment plus que de raison
et c'est ça qui est touchant chez Angel
en réalité ça la grand-mère de tout le
monde finalement et c'est ce qui a
touché ce qui a touché la voilà René
merci en tout cas être là je sais je te
sens très
envie de sortir de cette histoire aussi
hein ça y est Angel aussi il faut
qu'elle
aimerait qu'elle passe à autre chose et
on aimerait qu'elle puisse vivre
tranquille en gel aussi c'est trop puis
même pour les autres personnes qui se
font agresser et tout il faut que il
faut que ça arrête un peu tout ça là
c'est je veux dire ça aurait pu je peux
vous dire elle aurait pu être beaucoup
et pour moi c'est une tentative
merci merci en tout cas merci elle doit
regarder elle va regarder vous faites un
gros bisous et tellement mignonne je
l'ai vu elle était merci
[Applaudissements]